[Musique]
valorisant densha parce qu'à econo coton
amigo infinita érable iike nouveau Mali
se souvenir de profiter de la zone parmi la zone polaire
permet à l'économie de la milice élevée en Roumanie
de vivre alaikum alaikum Aliotti évêque
de la possibilité arabe d'otaku Nikita
[Musique]
m.  dépendez des connaissances des Indiens auprès d'
experts au sein des communautés, parfois
même si vous avez un réseau faible, vous pouvez
facilement leur envoyer des SMS et cela
vous guidera à moins que mr.  Je l'obtiens généralement rapidement,
cela me guidera et pour me laisser, je peux
même nous dire une partie du pasteurisateur
aujourd'hui, le temps l'humidité n'est pas
si bonne
[Musique]